we should mention uh the ricky has a new
special coming out super nature is
coming out on netflix uh next tuesday
may 24th
uh and i was watching it uh over the
weekend and i've now got a theory
because right before i watched it this
news broke that uh netflix sent all
their employees a memo saying like we're
going to allow artists to speak we're
not going to we're not going to cancel
anybody so if you want to cancel people
you might as well leave
now my back i watched your special and i
was like they literally put pre-emptive
measures in before ricky's special
really because 100
the netflix employees are going to get
mad again
well i mean i think either i don't know
what to say really to me there's nothing
controversial with that because it's
just jokes it's nothing we don't do it's
not as bad as the [ __ ] we've said today
i i i i think you know and we try to get
us cancer yeah
i even explained what irony is at the
beginning of the [ __ ] show
and everyone there you know i don't know
i'm gonna play two half a million people
no complaints they laughed at all the
things right but everyone's gonna
complain about everything you know
everything every single line someone is
going to complain either because they
hate it they don't they they don't get
it uh that it's coming after here's the
thing about comedy right you can i could
i can list
20 taboo subjects right everyone in the
world laughs at 19 of them and hates the
one that affects them you're delusional
if you think everyone in the world is
laughing at 19 out of 20 of your [ __ ]
well okay
i got a lot of percentages
yeah i think that i mean
are rich
you think though
people have felt this way
since
time since comedy started yeah people
but now we just hear them but we're
exactly right it that's exactly right
i've heard it before 20 years ago if you
complained about something you'd get out
a pen on paper and go dear bbc oh i
can't be bothered yes right now they can
fire for tweet and the [ __ ] press
pick up the tweet right and so people
are mad yeah they get clicked said 69
341 no no no no most people aren't
[ __ ] mad right most people don't know
about it yeah yeah well they weren't mad
until they read the article because
exactly one guy tweeted they wrote an
article about the tweet and then a whole
bunch of people who didn't watch the
special read the article the papers are
the worst as well because they do it
right there's papers in britain uh that
paparazzi they take a picture of an
actress right if they say so-and-so
looks gorgeous all the comments are
going she looks raging like if they say
look at this pig they go yeah she's a
[ __ ] dog they're told what to [ __ ]
think yeah yes well they turned on
johnny depp and then when people we were
like [ __ ] you we're with them they turn
that way the price they just go whatever
way that they're gonna get [ __ ] close
because there's only one way to do it
there's no way to do it ignore it all
right do your special get paid buy a
house ignore
[Laughter]
you know what's funny you can't let them
tell you what's funny you know what's
funny if it's funny
what no you know what's right
you know if you think it's jim is
disgusting and funny jim yes jim looks
like he's reading his poem again
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i'm just so bored with it
all it's so when you're predictable like
we've had 10 years of it now complex
people are complaining because they get
hurt they should be ignored when you're
ready wow straight ahead though when you
look at how like uh spotify stuck with
rogan and netflix stuck with chappelle i
think a lot of it will go away
and when you read when you read that now
there's nothing to do
it doesn't affect you when you read that
netflix sent that memo out though did
you think to yourself
oh
i wonder if that's because my special's
coming out in a couple of weeks i didn't
i think it was because it took that long
for them to to get that together i think
they always thought it i think they you
know
when chappelle thing broke like what was
it last november yeah you know they said
we're not interfere with the artist that
everyone said you know there's a
platform with you know and uh i i think
uh they they said to me ages ago dude
you know you want to warn i said
put the worst one you want but say say
this is the worst most effective in the
world if you want i don't give a [ __ ]
it's not i don't think there's anything
i don't think if aaron if people
understand the joke there is nothing to
be offended about in that it's a [ __ ]
comedy you're actually getting more
press when those people complain about
it of course more people are going to
watch it
that's how it works and anyone who's
ever under complaining shut up you gave
you a little speech captain obvious shut
the [ __ ] up captain obvious
1985
hey can i get you something like a watch
shut up
he'll sink his own ship that makes me so
happy
oh god
uh so yeah it's done for me i'm already
on my next thing i'm warming up my new
shower where where did you shoot it
uh london palladium okay last november
have you shot a special in the us right
uh i shot two i shot my two hbo ones uh
madison
square garden the
wamu and uh the second one was chicago
theater right so i've shot two there but
those two were sort of compilations of
like four english tours right with the
english bits taken out if you know what
i mean right you know and i made them
into two specials uh but um
uh no i've done i'd say i've done sort
of six where do you work out your stuff
just done in theaters yeah i hire a
theater for it for like 200 people
you know 10 15
right you don't go to clubs i don't know
it doesn't do me any good i don't do
that sort of thing i i have to because
there's a sort of like there's a theme
to it and i have to try
it's not the right atmosphere right you
can you you could work to kill in the
club but they've
the things have got to be alcohol proof
in a club and aren't people i want it to
be a bit more
yeah but they they drink they're
drinking but um
uh no
what i do is uh i'll do an hour but i'll
have three sort of chums doing ten
minutes each so i'll come out and i'll
compare them and i'll try the five
minutes out between right the accent and
it's a friendly crowd they come to see
and
more and more they want to see stuff
that won't make it into the show i say
that won't make it into it and they they
think they've seen someone that no one
else to see so they like peeking behind
the curtain they like i go this is new
but they like comedians losing faith in
real time yeah [ __ ] me that was [ __ ]
they get it gets the biggest lie i shot
my special last week
what did you say i would love you
[Laughter]
i shot my special last week 30 minutes
into the set oh this is so funny as i'm
as i'm walking out
um a lady they go robert kelly and i'm
walking out that's the intro the first
shot lady went to the bathroom and she
just runs by the shot sorry she was late
to get back to her seat i was just like
you [ __ ] motherf in my other you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so i think on stage then
my knee buckles because they have a
[ __ ] up knee understandable
[Laughter]
i'm in these nikes my wife gave me these
nikes i don't wear nikes i i'm old and
i'm fat i wear new balance you're not
fine
new balance
[Laughter]
stephen hawking didn't realize
new balance you and jupiter
[Laughter]
i'm killing it around 25 30 minutes in i
hear help her i'm like what and help her
please this guy's wife had an episode in
the second row from what kind of an
application i don't know i just looked
over and she was looking at her feet
and he didn't
something was happening and he's like
please help her so i'm like guys we need
help all of a sudden the place erupts
lights go up everything shuts down
i'm off the stage there's chairs on the
stage and i'm just standing there
looking like i felt like i was in a car
accident i'm just on the side of the
road like what the [ __ ] happened
she didn't die she's okay thank god was
she having a stroke or something i don't
know dude i all of a sudden i look over
and louie uh produced it he's like we're
good we're good i'm like we're not good
i don't know where the [ __ ] i am right
now and i went back up but everybody i
was [ __ ] up about it but like you're
saying everybody there was like that i
hope that's in the special i hope you
leave that in the special i hope that's
in the end you didn't do material after
it i went up a little bit i did of
course i started
riffing about this [ __ ] but i don't know
what i said it was like being in a fight
like i just went up and i just started
saying [ __ ] that they were laughing at i
don't know what it was said but
apparently it was i i transitioned good
because i i felt i was in my head the
whole time i had the same thing happen
to me
the exact
exact same thing
storytoppers she wanted to jump on
the guy who tops the sword i'm telling
you i had the same
i such a new character
so where's the special for i'm only
plugging this special now where's the
special coming out it's coming out uh in
september on louie's site louis louis
shot it directed he was [ __ ] nice
right my name comes out in june what's
it what's yours your code uh uh comics
anonymous i shot it at a 12 step we did
that we did something for mike uh mike
the stuff no not oh oh yeah
so what is it you doing you do an hour i
do an hour a new hour or a club
is it so when you're doing your your
club sets right yeah that's that's
crowd-pleasing stuff you'd see it
absolutely
it's not high brow cerebral
[Laughter]
but the opposite yes but then when he
does a special yeah you know what size
so when you do a special do you just get
all the stuff you ever done and dump it
and put it on to thing or do you write a
new special well i i have i got one like
six years ago right and we just do we
sell it and we just put it
just do that one again
yeah you're right no we we made a
mistake
with the edit we just put it on youtube
that one right what was the mistake with
the edit
we didn't have three we did it
it wasn't three minutes in yeah
it should have been opening and closing
credits i had nothing but good things to
say about yourself that's true
don't switch it i always say that it's
funny it's almost a compliment
yeah yeah it's like you're fat thanks
man
who wants a young thin handsome [ __ ]
comedian no one
[Laughter]
you're making fun of me i get off the
ride and then he [ __ ] hits yeah
he's so smart right quit the business
yeah
[Laughter]
i used to remodel houses i had a big
business
so just go in and do everything no yeah
mostly painting and roofing so you
should actually do a show about that
about remodeling houses you should start
doing that and do a shower
on youtube you can see my uh lancers
cameras no problem
what was the good idea i gave you
that
i have six going on seven albums and a
lot of my stuff you have either six or
seven who phrases it like no
[Music]
my seventh album i i just haven't edited
it then say you have seven albums no one
is
hasn't been on tv right so bobby said
take the best stuff from each of those
hours and make a two-minute special
[Laughter]
six going on seven specials is it it's a
big accomplishment six going on seven
well i've done six right but i'm doing
seven i'm not i can't say seven and i
don't want to say six i'll say six going
on seven
ricky how come you didn't correct me
when i plugged your special you didn't
correct me i didn't mention what number
special it was i didn't give you credit
for the amount of specials
what are you looking for depiction my
set the set is for my [ __ ]
special if you don't count the two
to uh this is my six since this
technically hasn't come out you're at
five going on six well it's happened
i've done it it's finished you have so
you're six going on seven
seven
do you have a favorite ricky do you have
a favorite favorite special uh this
one's coming out right may 24th yeah i
think i think my three best are
um
and people disagree because they [ __ ]
people well i i think it's humanity this
one on the next one i think that that's
right yeah i think so i've already
started the next one and uh you always
start with good intentions like this can
be the best one that's the that's the
best bit for me right um but um i'd say
it's out of this humanity yeah okay yeah
here's that
oh jesus what's he doing he's i don't
know what he's doing you're off my
office
you're off
ricky doesn't care
[Laughter]
you get going all right it was it was it
was a nice dm it was comfortable yeah
okay wait what happened no i said no no
no it was sweet there was nothing about
i don't know what he was i already did i
thought it scared him did you dm ricky
no yeah no no no no
no my my bit is the rude bit he said um
if you can spare 10 minutes after radio
or during one of the breaks we'd like to
run something by you no pressure looking
forward to hanging out and i sent back
you've ruined it
but
i read it on the golf course and after i
read it you ruined it my whole game went
to [ __ ]
i [ __ ] go what did i do to [ __ ] it up
and then i talked to my wife she goes i
told her first of all she goes
the other day she goes tell yeah talk to
him or talk then she goes after i told
her that she was didn't i tell you not
to whatever she's a turncoat she's like
right
you're a turncoat
i really like your bits that you put up
with you and your wife
you say one thing and she says she says
something like do you know what that
word means
it's just just
and he doesn't he does that no he does
that i also tell him
most fascinating little videos that they
put up i love it because i don't know
how
she stays like i don't know how she
doesn't get up and just walk out she's
talented she's direct your career is
going great yeah she can leave right now
yeah take the kids
but you don't know my way she's just he
looks like mr big in prison
[Laughter]
he looks like you've got to go to and
say
because yeah don't worry about it it's
fascinating that she loves him she
really loves she doesn't though she's
comfortable you're not a good person
where did you meet where did you meet
what do you mean i was at the commie
cellar and she was walking that's when i
was on last comic standing yeah
she walked into a house and he was
standing on the lawn holding a lantern